all right according to a new CNN article
too much bad news can make you sick well
they are the experts they've boy to
social media new technology 24-hour news
which allows you to experience
depressing stuff you never would have
decades ago Wow who could be responsible
for this a murder in one state a train
crash and another a wildfire here a
flood there they all come at you at once
it overwhelms you then comes disaster
fatigue numbing you to tragedy so how
does this make you sick the article
never shows any statistics about that
it's all hypothetical no evidence maybe
that could be the problem CNN here's my
theory it's not bad news at all that
makes you sick it's the you are bad news
when every story paints you as the
villain which happens daily let me show
you here is bad news polar bears are
disappearing here is you are bad news
it's because you mistreat the planet
here is bad news illegal immigration is
up here is you are bad news if that bugs
you you must be a bigot here is bad news
police shoot a minority here is you are
bad news because America you are racist
so how healthy is it to be told hourly
that you're heartless racist and killing
the earth that's most news except here
because we know that you're a good
person but you'll get it at other places
that the Democrat Party to CNN is their
megaphone they have the same message
you're bad
everything is viewed through the same
filter born from the campus which now
infects news and entertainment and it
creates only one conclusion
you are the oppressor you are guilty if
that doesn't make you sick it should so
you know what I love Dana they had out
CNN had another article right after that
and it was about how amazing America is
right now you got a great economy North
Korea low unemployment why are people so
sad that was an actual article that ran
after this one why are people so
stressed up CNN is they have no
self-awareness well also you do wonder
about whether people because actually
the polling doesn't even bear that out
right because if you ask people do you
think America is moving in the right
direction are you optimistic about the
future all of those number
are headed in a positive direction so it
might just be that the people that are
writing the headlines that the people in
their peer group and the people that
they're friends with they're miserable
it's confirmation bias Kimberly you
won't find that at Fox News because we
appreciate the viewer we don't believe
America is inherently evil like those
other jerk faces at the other cable
networks screw them because we're too
busy being happy and winning right
that's the thing it's such a good point
people go oh I don't want to watch the
news it's too depressing too upsetting
because you hear you get personally
blamed like it relates to you that
America is a bad place that Americans
are racist that Americans are only
concerned about themselves but when you
look at the real facts about what's
going on we are one of the most generous
countries if not the most generous
country in terms of helping out other
countries we have great record low
unemployment numbers now people are back
at work they're able to provide for
their families you see the numbers up
with women with minorities African
American community we are trying to do
even more to improve people's lives
these are all the positive good news
stories like Tina's book and the good
news is right that people want to hear
that and hear about the winds and not
constantly be made to feel bad about
themselves with slumped shoulders
because somehow you've done something to
be applied on the rest of the world
you're destroying the environment and
the rest of the world while you're at it
yeah well I will say that they they
touched on something that we talked
about here that technology and cable
takes every story it makes it national
so we think that all this stuff is
happening right now well I thought your
point was well-taken though they'd have
no statistical basis but I must say I
think that point that you're now making
about you know every earthquake every
murder is a national story it's also
true and it affects you so a lot of
people do what Kimberly was describing
which they say to me you know I don't
watch news as much as I used to yeah cuz
it one they think it's especially in our
audience that it's all anti-trump stuff
that's coming they don't want to hear
that but secondly the lot of it's just
depressing news there's all you know my
love is the every station does breaking
news breaking news
what is this breaking news yeah I don't
know well okay but if you catches your
eyeballs you're yourself like an
involuntary response your head swings to
the TV but I will say this I find it odd
coming from Miss
sir I hate these people yes that you're
saying that in fact we are The Love Boat
right here at FoxNews mmm that is true I
am a hypocrite
he got me there right do you have an
opinion you do a news program as well I
believe it's in on the mornings is it a
local program you just and of course
you're it's gonna be national I believe
it's most cable systems yes I was a
delightful show you have cooking
segments right and we used to have pet
of the day I know that we got too many
the rains got too high got it depress
the rest of the company so you see eight
that dog 65% one time it was not like he
does it every day 65% say they follow
the news most of the time 68% say
they're worn out by the news and here's
here's what I say when President Obama
or President Bush was president the one
thing about Fox is we don't program the
same story
one hour look at out different this show
is an old seriousness look how different
our show is for three hours there's not
Trump is great Obama's bad Bush's gray
Carter's fantastic we change gears if
you look at the other channels it's 45
minutes of how bad Trump is and then 15
minutes on how I wish Oprah was
president so that to me it shows a
program if you watch here people are
happier I would like to see CNN to a
study on why Fox viewers are so much
happier because we have a diversity of
views it allows you to get information
to make your own opinion as rather will
show you how to look why you should feel
bad I think they should call that this
Stelter effect well I don't when you
feel bad watching monitor the nation saw
mine the problem the problem and then I
know we got to go is that they'll take
one event and making it make it the rule
not the exception with everything